ANTHONY CAPORALE: First of all,
I want to thank you so
much for having me in today.
I'm really excited.
I am a huge, dyed-in-the-wool,
honest to gpd Google fanatic.
I'm a Gmail guy.
I'm an Android guy.
I live and die by all
of your products.
So I really, really appreciate
the opportunity to come in and
talk to you today.
Thank you so much.
My name's Anthony Caporale.
And I'm going to be talking
about whisky, if that's OK.
[APPLAUSE]
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Yeah?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Great.
So, we had a couple things I
want to talk to you about in
the whisky category.
But I'm really going to end
up focusing on scotch.
Because that's kind
of my love.
And to me, it's one of the more
interesting of the whisky
categories.
But I'm going to cover as
much of whisky as I can.
Just a little bit about myself
so you kind of know who this
person is who's going
to be yapping at you
for the next 60 minutes.
Come on in, come on
in, come on in.
I've been doing this
for over 20 years.
I started as a bartender about
20 years ago and then moved
into training.
Bought a restaurant.
Sold a restaurant.
I've been teaching
for a long time.
I've worked for some really,
really cool people in the
industry, including
Bobby Flay.
I'm currently the brand
ambassador for Drambuie scotch
liqueur, which we will be
tasting at the TGIAF.
Right?
At 5 o'clock.
So we're going to go right
from here upstairs.
And I have all my
boys upstairs.
And we're going to be tasting
some really, really cool
Drambuie cocktails.
But before we do that,
I want to teach you
about whisky and scotch.
So, first thing.
What is whisky?
Whisky is a huge category
right now.
Whisky is experiencing a boom
the likes of which if most
companies were experiencing
this boom, we
would want to be invested.
Just the bourbon category--
to give you an idea, bourbon
is up 17% year over, just
bourbon alone.
They can't make enough
bourbon.
You guys have recently probably
followed the Maker's
Mark fiasco where they had to
water down Maker's Mark in
order to meet demand.
And then they said no,
no, no, we're not
actually going to do that.
Because people hated
them, right?
So whisky is a huge, huge
category, but what it?
What is whisky?
We're not as familiar with
whisky as we once
were in this country.
Before prohibition, most of the
spirits we drank in this
country were whisky.
They were dark spirits.
At its most basic, basic level,
whisky is a distilled
alcoholic beverage made from
fermented grains--
that's really important--
and aged in wooden casks.
So that really, that last part,
aged in wooden casks,
that's the money.
That's what makes
whisky whisky.
So you start with
a grain product.
You ferment it.
You distill it.
And then you age it in wood.
Anything that you do that
follows those basic guidelines
falls into the whisky
category.
It comes from the Old English
word usquebaugh.
Everyone say usquebaugh
with me.
AUDIENCE: Usquebaugh.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: It's fun.
It's a fun word to say.
So, usquebaugh means
water of life.
And the reason that I bring that
up is because it shows
the importance that whisky
has had over time.
People literally put whisky on
the same level, in terms of
importance, as water,
and even more so.
Because back in the day, 1200,
1300, back before there were
clean municipal water supplies
when we were in the Old World
in Europe, if you drink the
water from the river, you were
going to get sick.
And you were probably
going to die.
Because this is how
it worked, folks.
You would go to the river, and
you would take your water.
You'd bring it back
to your house.
You'd clean with it.
You'd bathe with it.
You'd cook with it.
You'd do bodily functions
with the water.
Then you'd dump it out into
the curb, into the gutter.
And it would run back
into the river.
Great system, unless you lived
downstream from that city.
Because then the water you were
pulling out of the river
was all of their waste water.
Right?
So what happened was fermented
beverages and distilled
beverages-- beverages with
alcohol in them-- turned out
to be much healthier and much
safer to drink than water.
People who drank
water got sick.
People who drank beer, wine,
cider, whisky did not.
All right?
So water of life, usquebaugh.
Really, really important to kind
of put this in context.
Types of whisky.
We have scotch whisky,
obviously.
We have Irish whisky.
Bourbon is a type of whisky.
Rye, Canadian, Japanese.
Many, many countries today
are making their
own forms of whisky.
But I want you to know that
scotch isn't its own thing.
Scotch is scotch whisky.
Bourbon isn't its own thing.
Bourbon is bourbon whisky.
So all these things are grain
spirits that have been
fermented, distilled,
and aged in wood.
All right?
We see some spelling
variations.
You've probably noticed this.
Traditionally, without
the E is used
for Scotch and Canadian.
With the E is used for pretty
much everything else.
Whisky was probably invented
in Ireland.
However, the Scotch were the
first people to write down a
definition for whisky.
So they kind of get
credit for it.
So we think probably the Irish
invented it, but they were too
busy drinking it in order to
write down what it was.
So we gave it to the Scotch.
Couple of things about the
category of whisky.
UK, cereal grain mash.
I'm going to get a little
geeky with you guys.
Because I understand
there are a lot of
engineers in the room.
I actually have a mechanical
engineering degree.
So later on, we're going to get
a little geekier than I
sometimes get.
But distillation to less than
95% ABV, I'm going to talk
about the significance of that
in a minute when I do my
distillation demo.
Aging in oak casks--
and it has to be bottled at
not less than 80 proof.
All right?
80 proof is what percent
alcohol?
AUDIENCE: 40.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: 40.
Right.
You take the proof, you cut it
in half, and you end up with
the percent alcohol.
I'll talk about that
in just a second.
So before we get into whisky and
what it is, I want to talk
to you a little bit about
alcohol itself.
Because alcohol is the
active ingredient.
Alcohol is what makes
whisky whisky.
And the alcohol we're
talking about is
ethyl alcohol or ethanol.
It's volatile.
All right?
That means it evaporates
easily.
It's flammable.
It burns.
Colorless, and it is a liquid.
It's a central nervous system
depressant with significant
psychoactive effects.
That means it makes us want to
dance and sing karaoke and
hang out with people
in parties.
That's why we like it.
It's also toxic in relatively
small quantities.
That's just about
one half of 1%.
All right?
So this is why we kind
of got to be careful.
It is made through the
fermentation of sugar.
That's the only way that we
make ethyl alcohol, folks.
It's not made in the
lab somewhere.
Dow Chemical doesn't
produce it.
It's may through the
fermentation of sugar.
Who here is a home brewer?
Do I have any home brewers?
Yes!
Awesome.
You make beer, wine, cider?
AUDIENCE: Beer.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Beer?
Pretty easy to make
beer, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Just keep it sanitized.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: That's-- it's
difficult to make beer
taste good.
It's easy to actually
make beer.
I'm going to show you how easy
it is to make beer right now.
I have, in here, a mixture
of honey and warm water.
Pretty simple.
I have in here a yeast slurry.
And that's just yeast that's
been dissolved in warm water,
just to activate the yeast.
And all I'm going to do is
pour this yeast into this
honey, and we're going to watch
and see what happens.
Yeast is a unicellular
microorganism.
It's basically a plant.
It's the most common organism
on the planet.
We're all breathing yeast
cells right now.
They're all over the place.
And yeast only does
one thing, folks.
Yeast consumes sugar.
And it excretes alcohol
and carbon dioxide.
That's what yeast does.
So if I have a solution with
alcohol and carbon dioxide in
it after the yeast has done its
thing, what do we drink
every Friday afternoon at
about 5 o'clock that's
basically water with alcohol
and carbon dioxide?
AUDIENCE: Beer.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Beer.
Exactly.
So this is where we got
beer from, right?
So as we watch, we're going to
see a nice cap of carbon
dioxide form as this yeast
starts to convert the sugar in
the honey into ethyl alcohol
and carbon dioxide.
And that's fermentation in
its most basic form.
And that is where we
get ethyl alcohol.
Before we move on, I do want to
talk to you quickly about
the proof system in the US.
Because that's how we
measure alcohol by
volume, ABV, for spirits.
Spirit is liquors.
So we all know that, as I
mentioned, if we have 80 proof
and we want to convert that to
ABV, alcohol by volume, you
cut it in half.
And there's an interesting
story behind that.
Back in the day, we taxed
spirituous liquors.
We taxed things like vodka,
gin, rum, tequila.
But we didn't know if the tax
man came to your house and
wanted to tax your moonshine, he
couldn't necessarily prove
that it was moonshine
instead of water.
You could sit there all day and
argue that it was water.
And he would say no,
it's moonshine.
So what he would do is he would
take some of the liquid
in question.
He would put it in a little
spoon, and light it.
Now, as it happens, a mixture of
alcohol and water will burn
as long as there is at least 50%
alcohol in that mixture.
So he would light it.
If it lit, he would tax you.
Because it was at least
50% alcohol.
And the phrase became, 50%
alcohol, 100% proven that it
was taxable.
OK?
So that's where that
comes from.
And that way you'll always kind
of remember the math.
So cut the proof in half,
and you get the ABV.
We're actually starting to
measure spirits just by ABV
now because those tax laws
no longer apply.
And all we care about is how
much alcohol's in the bottle.
So pretty much all the spirits
that you're going to see now
have ABV on the bottle.
So, fermentation--
sugar consumed by yeast,
converted into ethanol and
carbon dioxide.
Take a look over there and see
how our fermentation is going.
We seeing a cap on that yet?
This has only been in here for
a couple of seconds, right?
We're going to watch.
This will probably
overflow the cap.
So [INAUDIBLE], at some point.
I may need you to run out
and take care of this.
But I'm going to try
and keep it here.
So we'll keep an eye on that.
whisky, I mentioned, produced
through the fermentation of
barley, primarily.
Barley.
I used honey because honey
has a nice sugar content.
Barley, not so much.
Not a lot of sugar in barley.
So we'll talk about
that in a minute.
I want you to keep that
in mind, where is
the sugar in barley?
But that's later.
So steps to making whisky.
First thing you need
to do is take that
barley and mash it up.
You need to break the husks.
You need to get to the middle
of the barley where all the
good stuff is.
That's called mashing
or washing.
And that produces a liquid
called wort.
It's spelled "wort," but it's
actually pronounced "wert."
And that is a small mash tun.
This is a large mash tun.
This is the Glenfiddich
Distillery in Scotland.
I was just there a
few weeks ago.
These are enormous.
You can see the scale.
Once you have that wort, you
then pitch the yeast just like
I did here.
And you can see that yeast
cap is growing.
And it begins to ferment.
It's usually done in
an open container
just like that glass.
This cap of CO2 essentially
forms a cover on top of the
wort so nothing else
can get in there.
Once this fermentation starts,
this is as good as sealed.
So even though this is called
open fermentation because it
is an open vessel, it's actually
a closed system.
This is a layer of CO2 that
keeps anything else from
getting in there.
So open fermentation is
still used today.
This is actually the Maker's
Mark distillery, I believe, is
where I took that picture.
So I mentioned how
fermentation--
fermentation produces beer.
Fermentation produces wine.
Fermentation produces cider.
And fermentation
produces mead.
Those are our four basic
fermented beverages.
Beer is from barley.
Cider is from what?
AUDIENCE: Fruits.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Fruits.
Good.
Pomaceous fruits, usually
apples, pears.
Wine, we all know
from grapes--
berries, actually, but
mostly grapes.
And mead.
I mentioned mead.
What is mead produced from?
Honey.
That's what I'm making
right here.
This is mead.
We think mead is probably
the oldest of all
the fermented beverages.
But the thing about fermented
beverages, folks, is because
alcohol is toxic, they stop
at a certain ABV.
The yeast goes dormant
or dies.
So you've never have wine at
higher than about 18% alcohol.
Beer, in America, 5%
or 6% alcohol.
If you want to go higher than
that, if you want to get to
that 40% alcohol or even higher,
you have to physically
pull the alcohol out.
You have to separate
the alcohol from
the rest of the liquid.
And you do that through a
process called distillation.
And that's really the core
of the spirits industry.
Distillation separates liquids
based on a difference in
boiling point.
So we know water, for example,
boils at about 212 degrees
Fahrenheit.
Turns out that ethyl alcohol
boils at 173.
So if I heat a mixture of ethyl
alcohol and water--
if I heat this mixture to about
175, the ethyl alcohol
will turn into a gas.
It will boil.
The water will remain liquid.
If I then capture that gas,
that ethyl alcohol gas, in
something like this and then
cool it back down below 173,
I've now separated the
ethyl alcohol out.
And I left back in the
pot just the water.
OK?
And that is distillation.
So I'm actually running here a
distillation demonstration.
In this pot, I have beer,
plain old beer.
It's exactly what this will
be in about two days.
OK?
So I'm doing the entire process
in front of you.
I now heat this up.
This is going to heat
to about 180.
The ethyl alcohol will turn into
a gas captured down here.
This is ice that will
cool it back down.
And dripping out of here in
just a few minutes will be
pure ethyl alcohol.
And I'm going to prove
that it's pure
ethyl alcohol to you.
How do you think I'm
going to do that?
AUDIENCE: Set it on fire.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Same way
the tax collectors did.
Exactly right.
So somebody keep
an eye on that.
Can you see that from
where you are?
You let me know if that
starts dripping.
OK, great.
So that is distillation.
So, these so far are all the
basic steps to making whisky.
I have cereal grains.
I mash them, mix them up with
water, and break them down.
I ferment them, and then
I distill them.
Unfortunately, all I have at
that point is moonshine.
I have just a clear distillate
that's very harsh and very
difficult to drink.
In order to turn it into
whisky, I need
to age it in wood.
And that's where the
magic happens.
This is basically a diagram of a
laboratory version of what I
have going on right there.
This is my favorite still in the
whole world because I'm a
huge "MASH" fan.
And it shows you how simple
this technology is, folks.
This is actually based on
a true story. "MASH" was
actually based on
true stories.
This was actually a war
zone in a tent, right?
And they were actually making
distillations in a
war zone in a tent.
This is the Glenfiddich
Distillery
in Speyside, Scotland.
These pot stills are exactly
the same as those, except
they're giant.
The second type of distillation
I'm going to
mention very, very briefly
is column distillation.
This is called a pot
still, a pot still.
It's also called
a batch still.
And that's because you
do it in batches.
You put some beer in here.
You distill it.
You empty this out, and
then you do it again.
Really, really great, but it
doesn't work so well for
industrial settings.
Because you have to keep
starting it and stopping it.
We're doing pretty good
on this, yeah?
Happens pretty quickly.
You have to keep starting
it and stopping it.
They came up with another way to
distill beverages based on
heat exchange that allows you to
consistently pump the beer
in and pull the alcohol out
because they have steam coming
in from the top, distillate
coming in from the bottom.
And you can just keep the
whole process going.
This is called a column
or continuous still.
We use this for grain
whiskies, generally.
So for those of you who are
really, really into scotches,
we have malt scotches and
we have grain scotches.
Malt scotches are generally
made from barley.
Grain scotches are generally
made from wheat.
They're lighter, and they're
a little cleaner.
If you're going for a lighter,
cleaner style of spirit,
you're going to use
a column still.
If you're going for a more
character-based style of
spirit, you're going to use a
pot still or a batch still.
So I just mention that so you
guys can be familiar with what
the two types of distillation
are.
This is what one actually
looks like in the field.
And now we have our distillate
that actually comes out as
what we call new whisky
or green whisky.
This then gets put
in a barrel.
Barrels were generally
used for wine, right?
Barrels were used to age wine.
I want you to remember
that wine was only
reserved for the rich.
In general, rich people
drank wine.
Wine's very expensive to make.
Grapes are very temperamental,
and it's a very
labor-intensive process
to make wine.
So the rich people drank wine.
Spirits, up until very recently,
were generally
consumed by the poor, by
the lower classes,
by the working classes.
Because all they wanted
was that alcohol kick.
So what they would do is take
whatever the byproducts that
happened to be in
the area, they
would ferment and distill.
And then they would age them,
and they would end up with
spirits that were very unique
to whatever regions you
happened to be in.
So, for example, in Italy, you
make a ton of wine in Italy.
The peasants would take
all the byproducts
of making that wine.
They would take the seeds.
They would take the stems.
They would take the leaves.
They would take everything that
wasn't actually used in
making wine.
They would take that home.
They would press all
that stuff again.
And believe it or not, there's
enough residual sugar left in
those wine byproducts
that they could
ferment that liquid.
And then they would
distill it.
And they would end up
with their peasant
spirit, which is grappa.
You've heard of grappa?
Grappa is made from the
byproducts of wine-making.
We've all had rum, yes?
Rum is a byproduct
of sugar making.
They would make sugar.
They would refine sugar.
When you refine sugar, you end
up with a ton of molasses and
a ton of sugar cane syrup, which
the rich people would
just dump behind the plantations
in giant lagoons.
And it would rain, and yeast
would fall in them, and it
would ferment.
And the peasants would take
that liquid home, and they
would distill it.
And they would end
up with rum.
So this is the story behind
most spirits.
And the reason I mention this to
you is because I want to go
to Scotland now, particularly
the UK, where their spirit is
based on barley.
And they end up with a
barley distillate.
And they now have
to store this.
And what are they going
to store it in?
Well, they're going to store it
in whatever the rich people
are done using, which
is wine barrels.
And in Scotland in particular,
it was sherry barrels.
Because all of the nobles
were drinking sherry.
So they would take their raw
distillate and put it in
sherry barrels, take
it out two or three
or four years later.
And lo and behold, it turned
into an amazing, amazing
elixir that they called
Scotch whisky.
Or in that corner, it was
just calling it whisky.
There was no other whisky.
It was just whisky.
And to this day, if you go to
Scotland and you order whisky,
you don't order scotch.
You order whisky, right?
So, barrels were traditionally
used for wines.
Once you put the alcohol in
the barrel, that ethanol
starts to dissolve really,
really great stuff
that's in the wood.
Starts to dissolve some of the
sugars in the wood, starts to
dissolve some the chemicals in
the wood, things like lignins,
which taste like vanilla.
Starts to dissolve some of
the caramels in the wood.
And all of those things
marry with the
spirit over the course--
ah, thank you for keeping
an eye on that.
All of those things marry with
the spirit over the course of
many, many years and end up
mellowing that alcohol and
turning it into this whisky
that we love so much.
So here's a cooperage.
People who make barrels
are called coopers.
This was taken just
a month or so ago.
And this is all in Scotland.
So you can age whisky
now in any number of
different types of casks.
And I want you to start
using the word cask.
Barrel is not the right word.
Cask is the word that we use.
A barrel is actually a specific
size of cask.
It's the most common size.
But cask is actually the
correct technical term.
French oak is mostly
used in Europe.
Oak is all we use, by the way.
Oak is the only thing that
you can age spirits in.
We've tried every other
type of wood.
Nothing works like oak.
French oak is mostly used in
Europe, and it imparts a
distinctive vanilla character
to the spirit.
American oak imparts
more of a caramel
character to the spirit.
In addition to that now, I
mentioned that these whiskies
were aged in casks that were
used for other things by the
wealthy people.
And in Scotland,
usually sherry.
They didn't have the luxury
of buying brand new casks.
These were peasants.
You used whatever happened
to be around.
So in Scotland, they were
using sherry casks.
That imparts a spicy character
to the whisky.
We now don't use sherry casks.
Most scotch is actually
aged in bourbon casks.
Because that's what we
have the most of.
So the vast majority of scotch
in the world is aged in Jim
Beam and Jack Daniels casks.
Because that's, again,
what we have.
That imparts more of a sweet
character to the whisky.
So if you taste scotch today
aged in bourbon casks, it's
significantly different from
scotch produced about 50 years
ago that's aged in
sherry casks.
And if you want to taste the
difference, taste pretty much
any scotch that you buy is
going to be bourbon.
But then buy Macallan.
Macallan, to this day,
is still aged
in 100% sherry casks.
So Macallan will give you a
really good idea of what
traditional sherry-aged scotch
will taste like.
And it is noticeably darker
and noticeably more spicy.
A couple of examples
of cask sizes.
I'd mentioned that just really
briefly I want to touch on
what this means.
I want you to think now in
terms of surface area.
If I have a very, very large
cask, I'm going to have much
less reaction with the wood for
a given amount of time.
So as I am creating whiskies
now, I can actually determine
how much effect the wood is
going to have on the whisky by
the size of the cask
that I use.
So if I age my whisky in a very
small cask, I'm going to
have much more interaction
with the wood.
If I age my whisky in a large
cask, I'm going to have much
less interaction
with the wood.
I can age some whisky in large,
some whisky in small,
and blend them.
I can age whisky in
a small cask for a
short period of time.
I can age whisky in
a large cask for a
long period of time.
I can control a whole bunch of
different variables just based
on the size of the cask.
I also will char the
inside of the cask.
That does two things.
One, it removes some of
the character from
the previous fill.
Whatever was in the cask,
some of that will
be removed by charring.
The other thing it does
is it caramelizes the
sugars in the wood.
OK, so any of you guys cook?
Who are my cooks here
in the room?
Yeah.
You brown onions, right?
We've all caramelized onions.
They actually turn
brown, right?
We've made caramel.
You take white sugar.
You heat it up, and
it turns brown.
That's called the Maillard
reaction.
That actually breaks complex
sugars down into simple
sugars, easier to digest so
they taste sweeter to us.
And that's what we're doing
with this cask,
the exact same thing.
So when I add something like
alcohol to the cask, it's now
going to dissolve those sugars
and incorporate those sugars
into the spirit.
AUDIENCE: You're getting
some dripping.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: What?
Thank you.
You guys are good.
And I'm going to keep
track of this.
So are we impressed with
fermentation, guys?
I mean, how's that?
For like, what--
15, 20 minutes?
It's as simple as that.
And believe it or not, there are
college kids all over the
country that are doing this
right now in their fridge.
You can literally take cider,
and you can put yeast in the
cider, and they put a
balloon on top just
to make an air lock.
They don't need to,
but they do.
And you will end up with
drinkable dry cider after
about three days.
And remember, the beautiful
thing about fermentation and
alcoholic beverages in general,
they're difficult to
make taste well.
It's difficult to make
beer taste good.
It's impossible to make a
fermented beverage that will
harm you unless you drink
too much of it.
But other than that, it
will be safe to drink.
And believe it or not, it will
be safer to drink than the
local water supply if we're
anywhere outside of a few
years hundred years
from today.
You're safer drinking a
fermented beverage than you
would be drinking from the
river, stream, or well.
All right?
Really, really simple stuff.
So let's see what we have
going on right here.
My handy dandy torch.
Good?
Can we see this?
Yes?
OK.
And that, folks, is
as difficult as
distillation gets.
So what I've done right in front
of you within the space
of about, what, 30 minutes,
is we've gone
from honey and yeast.
The only thing I skipped is I
took this and put it in a can.
But other than that, it was
the exact same thing.
Honey and yeast right
down to moonshine.
If I then put this in wood,
I end up with whisky.
So you've seen the whole
process, very, very low tech,
stuff that's been going
on for centuries.
OK, we can have--
getting back to the cask--
different levels of cask char.
The longer you char the cask,
the darker the roast.
And it's the same like coffee.
You end up with more caramel,
more sugars.
Darker char gives you a darker
character to the whisky.
This is what we do with
the cask after.
We just put them
in warehouses.
But now we come back to
the big question.
And this is really what makes
scotch so interesting to me.
Where is the sugar
in barley, folks?
We've all had--
many of us probably have not had
barley, but we've all had
things that are similar
to barley.
We've had granola.
We've had cereal.
Right?
We don't generally think
of grains as being
particularly sweet.
And we know that in order for
fermentation to happen, we
have to have sugar.
That's what yeast consumes.
And it has to be in solution.
We can't just have
a pile of sugar.
It's got to be in
water, right?
Which is why I did this.
So where is the sugar
in barley?
There isn't much.
Barley is a seed.
I think seeds, in general,
are amazing.
Seeds are basically little
lifeboats for baby plants.
Right?
That's what they are.
They're lifeboats
for baby plants.
And we have found seeds in
Egyptian tombs, believe it or
not, that we can then plant
and get to germinate.
That's how good seeds
are at preserving
the baby plant inside.
But there's a trick that they
have to use in order to be so
good at this.
We consume sugar.
Life consumes sugar,
including plants.
That plant needs
sugar to grow.
But if the mother plant were
to just surround the baby
plant with sugar, guess
what would happen?
Yeast would eat it.
Everything would eat it.
It would never end up being in
a tomb for 2,000 years and
then be able to germinate.
So plants came up with
a cool trick.
They took the sugar, and they
said, we're going to change
the form of the sugar
just a little bit.
And we're going to turn it into
something called starch,
which is a carbohydrate.
We're going to turn
it into starch.
Starch, now, actually, is
something that if you're
yeast, you can't act on.
So starch is something that
you can surround the plant
with, and nothing else will be
able to eat that starch.
Unfortunately, the plant
can't eat it either.
Before the plant can use
it, it has to be
converted back to sugar.
So the mother plant
does two things.
One, it surrounds the baby
plant with starch.
And two, it puts a little enzyme
packet in the seed.
And that enzyme packet
is activated
when the seed is planted.
When you plant the seed, the
enzyme packet breaks open,
converts the starch into sugar,
and the plant can now
use it in order to grow until
it breaks the ground and can
start photosynthesis.
But how does the seed know
when it's been planted?
When it gets wet.
That's the signal,
when it gets wet.
So if I have barley, which is
essentially starch, but I want
to convert that starch into
sugar so that I can ferment
it, what I have to do is trick
that barley into thinking it's
been planted.
So what we do is we lay
it out on a floor,
and we wet it down.
When we wet it down, that enzyme
starts to react with
the starch, converts the starch
into sugar, and the
baby plant begins to grow.
This is called malting.
And if you've heard the term
malted barley or malt, that's
what they're talking about.
Once that baby plant starts to
grow, we know the starch has
been converted into sugar, and
we need to then stop that
conversion.
And we do that by reversing the
process that started it.
We dry the barley out.
And we do that by generally
lighting low
fires under the barley.
It will dry the barley out.
It will stop that process.
And now, we can take
that barley.
We can mash it, as
I showed you.
We can ferment it.
And we can distill it.
So that whole process is called
malting, and that is
what ends up giving scotch
it's really, really
distinctive character.
Because in order to dry the
barley, we have to, as I
mentioned, light
fires under it.
And in Scotland, they don't
have a lot of wood.
What they do have
is peat moss.
And peat moss has a very
distinctive aroma.
I'm going to pass
it out for you.
Go ahead and pass that around
the room, and just nose that.
And that is the aroma
of peat moss.
That aroma from drying the
barley, that smoke character,
ends up staying with the whisky
through the grinding
process, through the washing
process, through the
fermentation, through the
distillation, through the
aging in wood for up to 25, 30
years, and into the bottle.
And we still don't understand
how that smoke character ends
up lasting through that whole
process, but it does.
And it's really, really
amazing to me.
And it's one of the things, as
I said, that makes scotch so
interesting.
And it's really important that
we understand why this malting
process is necessary.
And it's all about making that
sugar accessible to the
distiller before it was
accessible to anything else.
Because if that plant was
surrounded by sugar, it would
never be able to survive
as a seed.
Make sense?
OK.
So here we have what I call
the magic of malting.
So to produce ethanol from
grains, you have to convert
the starch back to ferment-able
sugars through
the process called malting.
This is starch and water, yields
maltose, which is a
form of sugar that we use
to ferment, and oxygen.
That's the malting equation.
Grains are made to germinate
by soaking in water, which
develop the enzymes.
This is called modifying the
starch back into sugars.
And this is the process that
allows us essentially to form
the spirit industry.
The maltose that we produce is
then broken down into fructose
and glucose.
Yeast can then convert those
fructose and glucose molecules
into ethanol and carbon dioxide
through fermentation.
Here's your equation.
Glucose yields ethanol
and carbon dioxide.
So that is essentially
the chemistry
behind the spirits industry.
And I say that every drop of
alcohol is essentially a ray
of star shine.
Because that's really where
this all comes from.
Our bodies retrieve the energy
stored in the chemical bonds
of ethanol through the oxidation
to acetaldehyde and
finally acetal.
And basically, I like to say
that's why I hate "The
Matrix." Because if you
remember, in "The Matrix,"
they never accounted for the
fact that energy was being put
into the system.
They were just constantly
harvesting people, right?
You have to have energy put into
the system at some point.
And it always has to start
with sunshine.
So this is what floor malting
looks like, just a bunch of
barley laid out over
the floor.
This is what a peat
bog looks like.
This is where we actually
harvest the peat that we'll
then use to dry the malt.
And this is what the malted
barley looks like.
They'll actually--
they can tell when to stop the
malting process by the length
of those rootlets.
And the master malter will
actually go through and pick
up a handful of malted barley
and measure the
length of the rootlets.
And by the length of the
rootlets, he can tell whether
or not the sugar has been
completely modified.
So let's look at a summary
now, of making whisky.
First, we have to harvest
the grain.
Then, we have to
mill the grain.
We have to crack the
shell of the grain
to get to the inside.
We wash it into wort.
We then ferment the wort into
beer, distill the beer into
new whisky.
We age it into casks.
At that point, we can now blend
the whisky, very, very
common in the industry.
We've all had Johnny
Walker, yes?
We've all had Dewar's.
These are all blended
whiskies.
What a blended whisky is, you'll
take whisky from a
number of different distillers,
a number of
different ages, and you'll
blend them all together.
And the idea is to produce a
consistent whisky over time.
So if whisky A comes in a little
sweeter than usual,
you'll maybe use a little less
of it in the blend in order to
maintain a consistent profile.
Next time it comes in a little
less sweet, you'll use a
little more of it.
But your whisky blend,
the profile, will be
consistent over time.
Those are called blended
whiskies.
The alternative to a blended
whisky is what's called a
single malt whisky.
And we've all had single
malt scotches.
And a single malt whisky is
a single distillery and
generally a single
harvest of malt.
So it's much more difficult
to maintain
consistency over time.
Any variation in that malted
whisky is going to show up in
the end product.
Whatever comes off the still,
whatever comes out of that
barrel, that's what's going
to end up in the bottle.
So if you're trying to make
Macallan, and you end up with
a batch that doesn't quite taste
like the way Macallan
used to taste, you have to sell
that batch to a blender.
You can't bottle it as
Macallan because your
customers are not going
to want it.
They're not going to
be used to that.
So single malt is a little
bit riskier to make.
The peat's making its
round, the smoke?
Right?
Pretty intense, yes?
So some of the flavors that
we're looking for in whiskies
in general, obviously grain is
going to be the primary flavor
in all whiskies.
Cereal, sometimes described as
bran, biscuitty, malty, mashy.
Wood is the next most
prominent flavor.
And there are some distillers
that actually say wood is the
most prominent flavor.
A lot of the folks that I work
with today are saying that 60%
of the flavor of any whisky
comes from the wood.
And they're actually investing
a lot of money in what they
call wood technology.
Has anyone ever tried
Maker's 46?
No?
OK, so we all know Maker's
Mark, yes?
Maker's Mark came out
with a new bourbon.
Now, Maker's Mark
is a bourbon.
They came up with a new bourbon
call Maker's 46.
It was the first new product
that they'd introduced in
about 55 years.
Maker's 46 is what they called
it, and people can't figure
out why they called
it Maker's 46.
People think that it's
46 years old.
People think that
it's 46 proof.
46 is actually the number
of what they
call the wood profile.
Out of 100 different types of
wood that they tested, they
ended up using the 46th.
So they called Maker's
46 Maker's 46
based on the wood profile.
And my point here is that they
tried 100 different types of
wood charred 100 different ways
before they came up with
one that they felt worked.
And that's the level of
investment and time that
people are putting into
wood technology today.
Because wood has so much
influence on the final
character of the whisky.
All right, so oak, cedar, nut,
marzipan, walnut-- all these
things can come from wood.
In addition to that, we have
what we call sweet aromatics.
And that's things
like vanillas,
caramels, maple syrup.
Believe it or not, those also
come from the wood.
And that's from the
caramelization of sugar.
And then we have the
spice component.
And the spice component also
comes generally from the wood.
There's a little bit added by
the cereal, but most of it is
from the wood.
Fruit and floral, we can get
everything from cherries,
oranges, blackberries,
peaches to things
like rose and lavender.
For Scotch and Irish whiskies,
we have peat, which you guys
all just smelled and tasted, and
then the astringent notes
that come from the
alcohol itself.
So let's talk now a little bit
about scotch whisky in
particular, so that you have
an idea of what the scotch
whisky regulations are.
One, in order to be called
scotch, it has
to be made in Scotland.
And believe it or not,
that's a revelation
to some folks, right?
You can't call it scotch if
it's not made in Scotland.
It has to be made from malted
barley, and it has to be
distilled to less than 95%.
So now that you guys know a
lot about fermentation and
distillation, I want you to
start thinking about-- when I
say things like, it has to be
distilled to less than 95%
alcohol, let's talk about
what that means.
Why would they restrict the
percentage that I can
distill whisky to?
Why would they say I
can't distill it
above a certain percent?
Any thoughts on that?
AUDIENCE: --the flavors.
Won't you get a change in the
flavor profile, if it's 5%?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: You bet.
Yep.
You get a change in the
flavor profile.
The more pure the alcohol coming
off the still, the less
character of the base grain
that comes with it.
So think about that
for a second.
If coming out of this still is
99% ethyl alcohol, there's
almost nothing left of
the original base
grain in that 99%.
If I reduce that to 80%, let's
say 20% is water that comes
from the base grain.
And with that water is
going to be essential
oils, asters, aromatics.
So the lower the percent you
distill to, the more original
character of the base
grain you preserve.
So for a spirit like whisky
where we want that base
character, we want that grain
character, you want to
restrict the distillation ABV.
Can you think of a spirit
where they would want to
distill to a very high percent,
where they want very
little of the base character?
AUDIENCE: Vodka.
ANTHONY CAPORALE:
You've got it.
Who said vodka?
Yes.
Vodka.
Vodka wants to be odorless,
colorless, tasteless.
That's what it wants.
So vodka has to be distilled to
a very, very high percent.
Whisky says no, you
can't distill
above a certain percent.
We want that base character.
OK?
I mentioned pot distillation
and column
distillation early on.
Again, now you know enough about
distillation, I can talk
about that a little bit.
With a column distillation or
a continuous distillation
process, I want to take
a look at what we have
going on right here.
With a still, if I'm doing a
batch distillation, I have
water and alcohol, and
it starts to heat up.
Before it gets to about 175,
there are other things in here
besides water and alcohol.
There are things that
come from the
grain that are in there.
There are oils.
There are esters.
There are all kinds of other
things in there.
Some things good, some things
not so good, all
based from the plant.
Before that alcohol starts to
turn into a gas, other things
start to evaporate first, things
with a lower boiling
point than alcohol.
We call those the heads.
They have certain flavors.
Then the alcohol starts to turn
into a gas and evaporate.
We call that the heart.
That's pure ethanol.
Once the alcohol is done, other
things with a higher
boiling point than the alcohol
start to evaporate.
We call those the tails.
And those also have
flavors and odors
associated with them.
What we really want
is that heart cut.
We want the ethanol.
But in a pot or batch
distillation, we
get the heads first.
Then we get the heart.
And then we get the tails.
The distiller can decide what
cut he's going to take.
So I want you to think about a
couple things now, one from an
economic standpoint.
You want to take the largest
cut possible, because
everything that you're not
putting in the bottle, you're
throwing away, and
that's waste.
So you want take the largest
cut possible.
But the larger the cut you take,
the more heads and tails
end up in the bottle.
And that oftentimes gives
you odors and aromas
that you may not want.
During prohibition, for example,
we've all heard of
bathtub gin, right?
We know that during prohibition,
alcohol wasn't
particularly high quality.
Moonshine, to this day, has a
reputation for making you go
blind, right?
Because moonshine produced in
the mountains of West Virginia
by a guy who probably doesn't
have a Ph.D. In chemistry,
he's just taking the
whole thing and
putting it in a bottle.
He's maximizing his profits.
Those heads and tails
will make you sick.
They will make you blind.
They're toxic.
OK?
They also do, however,
contribute flavors and odors
to the final product.
So you take too much and you
end up with off odors, off
aromas, and some toxins.
You take too little,
however, and you're
not making any money.
So there's a happy medium in
there that you have to decide
on what you're going to take.
That's pot distillation
or batch distillation.
Column distillation, because
it's continuous, you don't
have to worry about that.
There's heads when
you turn it on.
And then it runs for weeks.
Heart, heart, heart,
heart, heart.
And then tails when
you turn it off.
So a column or continuous still
is a much cleaner, purer
method of distilling alcohol.
And believe it or not, with
whisky and scotch whisky, in
particular, you're not allowed
to use column distillation for
single malts.
Because they don't want
it to be that clean.
They want the character that's
imparted by some heads and
some tails.
They don't just want
pure ethyl alcohol.
So a couple of interesting
things on this slide.
One, we're limiting the percent
ABV for distillation
in an attempt to preserve
character
of those base grains.
We're also saying pot stills,
baby, in an attempt to
preserve the character
of those base grains.
So do you see how whisky and
scotch whisky in particular,
it's very, very important that
they preserve that malted
barley character in the bottle
as opposed to, again, some
spirits that we can talk
about like vodka,
where that's not important.
And this is one of, to me,
one of the really, really
interesting things about whisky,
is it's all about
preserving that grain
experience.
Real quick, and then I'm going
to wrap up so that we can go
drink, but again, I just want
you to know a little bit about
some of these things
in Scotland.
There are four basic regions
that produce Scotland, and
then one that doesn't really
do a whole lot.
We have the lowlands,
the highlands, Islay
scotches, and Speyside.
Campbeltown doesn't produce
a whole lot anymore.
The one I want to point out for
the average person-- or
the two, actually--
Islay and Speyside.
So Islay scotch, if you like
that peat aroma, if you like
that smoke that I passed
out, you want
to drink Islay scotches.
All right?
You may want to write
that down.
It is pronounced Islay.
And Islay scotches are known for
producing very peaty, very
smoky scotches.
Speyside is the largest
region--
not the largest geographically--
they produce the most scotches
and they produce generally
what's considered to be the
classic scotch whisky.
So if you want to get started on
very classic malt scotches,
look for Speyside scotches.
And we're actually going to
taste you, when we go
upstairs, we're going to taste
you on Drambuie 15, which is a
Speyside malt.
OK?
Any questions?
No?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is it always the
same years, like 12, 15?
ANTHONY CAPORALE:
Great question.
So the question was, why do you
always see the same years
on the bottle?
One thing about years, know that
the year is the youngest
scotch in the bottle, by law.
So if the bottle says 12, there
may be older scotches in
that bottle, but there can't be
anything younger than 12 in
the bottle.
Convention has said that we're
going to bottle scotch at 6
years, 8 years, 12 years, and
15 years, just convention.
You'll see scotches
bottled at 17.
bottled at 25.
It's just a convention that
the industry has sort of
adopted over time.
Anything else?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How does
sour mash work?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Sour mash
is an American tradition.
And sour mash is what they
use for bourbons
and Tennessee whisky.
And all sour mash means is
that they use a starter.
Anyone bake bread here?
Do I have any bread bakers?
You know sourdough bread?
Sourdough bread is
always started by
the same yeast strain.
They'll actually preserve the
yeast from batch to batch, and
they will seed the next batch
with the yeast from it.
Because yeast is really what
contributes most of the flavor
to these things.
And sour mash just means that
they will seed it with a batch
from the previous distillation
or fermentation, rather.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You said earlier
bourbon is whisky, but you
also can also age whisky
in bourbon casks.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are you just reusing
the cask repeatedly?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Yes.
So bourbon whisky now, in order
to be called bourbon,
you have to be made in
the United States,
as opposed to Scotland.
Not Bourbon County, folks.
It just is the United States.
And the base grain in
bourbon is corn.
Because that's our base grain.
That's what we have here
in this country.
So bourbon is a whisky.
Bourbon has to be made
in new casks by law.
You don't make bourbon in
a cask that was used for
something else.
Brand new American oak casks.
So when you're done making the
bourbon, you only have two
things you can do
with that cask.
You can throw it out, or you can
sell it to a scotch whisky
manufacturer.
Because bourbon can only
use new casks.
AUDIENCE: Did you have to get
some kind of license to
operate that still?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: If it's bigger
than one gallon, which
this is not, or if it's not
being used in a laboratory or
educational setting, then you
need to have a distilling
license to operate it.
AUDIENCE: So, [INAUDIBLE]
a laboratory
or educational setting.
What's considered a laboratory
or [INAUDIBLE]
educational setting?
[LAUGHTER]
ANTHONY CAPORALE: It's
a good question.
You probably don't have one.
This would be considered
a laboratory
or educational setting.
A school would be considered
a laboratory
or educational setting.
A laboratory would be considered
a laboratory or
educational setting.
AUDIENCE: What about
filtration?
ANTHONY CAPORALE:
Filtration of--
AUDIENCE: Of scotch,
do they do that?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Yeah, so--
in other words, do they do
it, how do they do it.
AUDIENCE: They do something
that's like filters,
[INAUDIBLE] talk about.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
They'll talk about that as
a sort of evil thing.
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Yeah.
So filtration, there's two
theories of filtration.
One is that it's totally fine,
and it's a good thing because
it clarifies the liquid.
And two is that it completely
ruins the scotch, and don't
ever do it, right?
So all we're trying to do with
filtration is remove solid
particulates from the scotch.
And there are a bunch
of different ways
that they do it.
They can add pectin.
They can do chill filtration.
I personally think that it will
remove a little bit of
the character from the scotch.
But I've had tons and tons
of filtered scotches.
Most of the scotches that we've
all had in our lives
have been filtered, and
they're delicious.
There's nothing wrong with it.
But the scotch purists will tell
you that they're not fans
of filtered scotch.
AUDIENCE: Do you know what
causes the flavors from the
grain, is it the water, or the
barley, or is it the mixture?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: What causes the
different flavors, depending
on where it is in Scotland?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Yes.
What causes the different
flavors, really, really good.
So, let's go to the map.
So this is our scotch regions.
This is the Highlands.
This is Speyside.
This is the Lowlands,
Campbeltown, and Islay.
So Islay, you can see are
all island regions.
So what causes the flavor that's
characteristic to the
Islay scotches is one, peat.
There are no forests
on the coast.
There's only peat bogs.
So when they do the malting
process and they dry the
barley, they're using peat
to light those flames.
That's number one.
Number two, all of the air here
is full of salt, right?
Because you're on the coast.
And that salted air will
permeate the casks, because
wood is porous, and get into
the casks and impart a
saltiness to the scotch.
If you go into the Highlands
now, this is a much more
forested, wooded area.
The water is much cleaner and
purer than you're going to get
on the coast.
You guys have all had water in
Florida, or Virginia Beach, or
the Hamptons.
Totally different character
from water that's
from upstate New York.
Exact same thing
going on here.
Also, the vegetation is very
different in these regions.
And you've heard the term
terroir with wine.
It has to do with if you boil
down to the science of what
terroir is, it's the
local chemicals.
It's things in the local plants,
things in the local
soil, mineral formations.
All those things that vary from
region to region, whether
it's clay soil, whether
it's rocky soil,
whether it's sandy soil.
So all of these things are going
to manifest themselves,
not only in the water, but in
the actual grain and sometimes
in the air, and in the wood.
So all of that will combine
to change the
character of the scotch.
AUDIENCE: I think I missed
something about the
distillation.
So you said that the output
there is almost
100% alcohol, right?
ANTHONY CAPORALE:
Here, not quite.
But, let's pretend.
AUDIENCE: But then how do
you get to the 40%?
ANTHONY CAPORALE:
Good question.
Really good question,
great question.
You didn't miss it.
I skipped it because we're
trying to do this in a short
amount of time.
When you pull it out of the
barrel, it will come out of
the barrel at, let's call it 115
to 120 proof, 60% alcohol.
You then will take it and add
water to that whisky that you
pulled out of the barrel
before you
put it in the bottle.
You'll actually, what
they call reduce
it, by adding water.
That water that you add will
also affect the flavor.
It used to be that you were
making scotch up here.
You would pull the scotch
out of the barrel.
You would add water from this
region into the bottle, and
then you would ship it.
What they do now, unfortunately,
is they take
the scotch from here.
They put in a tanker truck.
And then they ship it
down to Glasgow.
And then they take scotch from
here, they put it in a tanker
truck, and they ship
it down to Glasgow.
Once it gets to Glasgow, they
take Glaswegian water, fill up
the bottles, and then ship it
to the rest of the world.
Because it's a lot
cheaper that way.
OK, but really, really
good question.
So we're always adding
water before we put
it back in the bottle.
AUDIENCE: What regulation
is there for that?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: There is
no regulation for that.
And I'm not supposed to tell you
that, but I love you guys.
It's one of the dirty
secrets of scotch.
AUDIENCE: How do you make sure
there's no methanol in there?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Very,
very good question.
So the methanol is actually
going to be in the
heads and the tails.
So the question is how do you
make sure there's no methanol,
which is wood alcohol.
And there is.
It will be in the heads
and the tails.
So you have to be very
careful what you cut.
It's one of the things you have
to make sure that you're
not including methanol
in your cut.
AUDIENCE: So the producers
have a test probably,
afterwards?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Yeah.
And they're actually
ridiculous at it.
These guys, they can
tell by smell.
These guys have been doing this
for like 40, 50 years.
What they'll do is at some
point in the distillation
process, there's an
open container.
And they'll actually
dip and smell.
You would think that
they would be doing
like a chemical test.
I was hoping they were doing a
chemical-- but they're not.
They can actually smell, and
they'll know where in the cut
they are just by smell.
It's really, it's crazy.
AUDIENCE: Well now, I
have two questions.
So why is it in the head and
the tail, instead of one
according to the boiling?
ANTHONY CAPORALE:
No, it's not.
Methanol is going
to be in the--
I'm going to get this wrong.
I think methanol is going
to be in the tails.
It's one or the other.
I forget which one
it is though.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: --region water thing,
so we can taste the
difference?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Is what?
AUDIENCE: Are there any brands
that don't use the Glaswegian
water so we can taste
the difference?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Edradour
doesn't.
And--
AUDIENCE:Talisker insisted
that they use--
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Right.
Talisker doesn't.
There's a few brands
that don't, but the
majority of them do.
AUDIENCE: Where are you getting
the ABV, are you using
a hydrometer, a refractometer?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Yes.
They're using a hydrometer.
AUDIENCE: So wine usually
ages in the bottles.
Does whisky have that
aging quality?
So once the whisky's put in the
bottle, does it over time
get [INAUDIBLE] character,
or not really?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Once you put
in a bottle, it becomes
completely non-reactive.
Was that your question?
AUDIENCE: But wine, for example,
you also put it in
the bottle, and it doesn't
really react, but what happens
is there are substances
which break down, and
that's how it ages.
So does whisky have anything
like that?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: No.
Once you put whisky in a bottle,
everything stops.
So whisky can last--
unlike wine, whisky actually
will last almost indefinitely
if it's sealed properly
in a bottle.
It's completely non-reactive
once it's in the bottle.
It has to do with the fact that
there's less solids in
it, and there's much higher
alcohol content.
If you're familiar with things
like port and sherry, which
are what we call fortified wines
where they actually add
alcohol back to the wine, the
reason they do that is so that
when you put it in a bottle, it
will last longer, and then
you can ship it.
Port and sherry was actually
developed for shipping, some
of the first products that were
specifically developed
for export.
And that's one of
the reasons why.
You increase the alcohol
content, it lasts longer in
the bottle.
AUDIENCE: You may have
said this earlier.
But I see Drambuie on
the logo, so where
does that come in?
ANTHONY CAPORALE:
Great question.
I probably should have talked
about that more,
since that's my brand.
So Drambuie, just so that you
know, I am the national brand
ambassador for Drambuie.
Drambuie is a scotch liqueur,
which means it's scotch that
has sugar or some sweetener--
in our case, honey--
and spices.
So we have liquors or spirits,
which is what we were talking
about-- whiskies--
so rum, vodka, gin, whisky.
All those things are liquors,
or spirits.
Then we have liqueurs or
cordials, which are
essentially spirits that
have sweetener and
flavors added to them.
And those are things like
Frangelico, Chambord,
Cointreau, Gran Marnier,
and Drambuie.
So you have to have flavoring
and sweetener in order to be
called a liqueur or cordial,
interchangeable.
Drambuie happens to be a
scotch-based liqueur.
So it is a blended scotch, 80
proof, blended scotch just
like Dewar's.
And we add heather honey
and a proprietary blend
of herbs and spices.
And you will taste
that upstairs.
And you can taste it straight,
and we also have cocktails.
And we also have a new product
called Drambuie 15, which is a
15-year-old Speyside single
malt, not a blended scotch.
It is actually a blend
of single malts.
And they're all 15 years old.
And they're all from Speyside.
And to that, we then add our
Drambuie elixir, which is the
sweetener and the herbs.
But it is a scotch, and that's
one of the reasons why I'm
sort of into this whole
scotch thing.
AUDIENCE: If I'm a home beer
brewer, I can make a decent
batch of beer in
a week or two.
If I am a home distiller, am I
waiting to make three years to
make something that
tastes drinkable?
ANTHONY CAPORALE: You're
not allowed to be
making whisky at home.
[LAUGHTER]
ANTHONY CAPORALE: That's
number one.
Number two, no.
You can make your beer.
You can distill it
very quickly.
If you want to age it in a cask,
you're probably looking
at about five years.
I don't know.
I've never tried it.
I swear though.
AUDIENCE: Will you tell us a
little bit about you know,
some people say drink it
on the rocks, versus--
ANTHONY CAPORALE: Yes, good.
Guys, you got do me a favor.
If you really want to learn more
about this than I can do
in an hour, take
my class at the
Institute of Culinary Education.
We do three hours of this.
You taste 35 different
whiskies.
It's really, really great.
And I will get even
deeper into this.
But one of the things that I
will tell you, when you taste
spirits, particularly whiskies,
please open them up.
So that means add
water to them.
So if you have ever have-- if
any of you guys have a friend
when you go out and you
order whisky, and
then you look at them.
And you want ice, but you won't
because you're with
them, and you know they're going
to laugh, don't hang out
with that person anymore.
Because they don't have your
best interests at heart.
I want you to add water.
When you do tastings with
distillers, with the guys who
make this stuff, if you sit down
at a distillery with the
master distiller, he's going to
give you a glass of whisky,
a glass of water, and
a medicine dropper.
And he wants you to add
water to the whisky.
All right?
80 proof is a number that we
came up with for shipping, not
for drinking.
OK?
It's for shipping.
We want you to open it up.
So add water, add ice.
I tell people up to equal
parts water is fine.
If you drink 80 proof whisky,
your mouth, it burns.
It does.
And it's supposed to.
Because it's toxic, remember?
I put that up early on.
It's toxic.
So what you'll see is if you
do this with a master
distiller, you put a drop of
water, and then you taste it.
Then you put another drop of
water, and you taste it.
And you keep doing that.
One drop along the line, all of
a sudden the burn's going
to go away.
It's just going to shut off.
It may be 12 drops for you.
It may be 20 drops for you.
But it's going to be the same
every time for each person.
And that's called your
alcohol threshold.
So what they ask you to do is
write that number down.
And then the next time they
give you sample, put those
number of drops in and
then taste it.
OK?
Because if you don't do that,
you're not tasting anything.
All your tongue is telling you
is, this is poison, spit it
out, please.
We don't want that.
So add water.
I add ice.
I only drink whisky
with full rocks.
That's how I like it.
And believe me, I know
what I'm doing.
So please, water and
ice to taste.
There's nothing wrong with
drinking what we call neat,
which is right from the
bottle into the glass.
That's fine.
But if you don't enjoy that--
and most people don't--
please, please, please
add water, add ice,
until you enjoy it.
That's what we want you to do.
Thanks for asking that.
Anything else?
You guys thirsty?
Let's go.
[APPLAUSE]